車の写真があるかなと思って
あんまりないんじゃない?
あんまりの3年ずっと乗ってなかったし
そう?
そう、一度だけ何故か言った時
パパだけ乗っちゃったりして
得意そうに乗ってたの思い出し
かわいい
これハロウィンのパンプキンかと思う
これ、教会?
うん
嘘
カモスケさんおかしい
え、これ何の時だ?
初世代か何かやった時?
うん、だってアンミとリキと
大輝もやったっけ?
うん
3人
リキさんだけは
それこそファルラーションがね
大子と妹たちと一緒に
嫌だからリキだけ大人と一緒にしようとか
良かったね
よかったね
いや、ファルラーションしか覚えてないね
これもヒーロー
でもあの時まだアンミたち英語できなかったから欲しかったね
そう
かわいい
大輝まだ髪の毛がない
うん
これじゃもっと古いかな
これ、このジャケットまだ持ってるんだよ
うん
あ、そう
どこ?
それ
あ、これ、えっと、靖国神社のお盆のお祭りだと思う
あ、そうか
お正月とかもね、大変なのよね、あそこね
うん
でもこの頃なんかあんまり食べ物売ってはいけなくなってたの、お正月は
え、なんで?
あんまり思うから、みんながもうピックピックみたいになっちゃうからね
あ、そうか、これもお正月じゃん、だってみんなジャケット着てるから
めめいっぱい色々運転してくれてね、毎日
しかも女の子がたくさんのお祭りだと思うよ